i can only assume that
you will enjoy educating your family
about how the coast guard is quote
the hard nucleus around the navy forms
in times of war you are
quite you're a really dull class
i mean come on man is the sun getting to
you
i would think you'd have an opportunity
when i say that about the navy to clap
talk about the pot calling the kettle
sleepy
[Applause]
[Music]
yes all right if you enter the phrase
blue lives matter into google you'll
find a long list of articles
explaining how racist it is i never knew
that
what i do know is that 48 officers were
shot and killed in 2020
and they do matter to me and probably to
you oh obviously to you
15 were also struck dead by cars on the
side of a road likely
assisting someone who needed help did
you know 2020 was one of the deadliest
years for cops
ever 264 deaths from numerous causes
the highest killer kovid obviously but
you don't hear about this much
and i also wonder how many minority cops
died last year
but i probably shouldn't bring that up
either since caring about their lives
that could be bigoted too so where does
this delusional
nationwide smear of a selfless
occupation
lead us to sheer stupidity
in a few days there's going to be a gay
pride parade in nyc
and you know who may be banned the cops
according to abc news the event
organizers announced that police will be
banned from all pride events
all the way up through 2025 seems kind
of harsh
2025 the biden era
my question how will anyone at pride
know who the real cops are
trust me trust me i've been tricked a
few times
once by this guy
[Laughter]
the organizer also wants to reduce
police security and first
responder presence you know because in
large gatherings of hundreds of
thousands of people
you definitely don't need those guys
all of this of course is to please the
woke a funny term since it only applies
to people who live in a dream world
says andre thomas who's the co-chair
quote we know many lgbt cops
but what the institution represents
sometimes to a person of color or trans
person is violence and that doesn't make
you feel safe
so they'd rather feel safe than be safe
so how can you organize a huge public
event and unilaterally decide
that cops can't be near it i mean can i
do that
i mean if so i would like to formally
announce that national greg gutfeld day
happens this saturday thank you
it happens this saturday from 10 a.m to
3 p.m i'll be parading down fifth avenue
on a homemade float
based on the golden girls i'll be
dressed as rose
for height reasons i can still fit into
her house coat
feel free to park on the sidewalk and
throw glitter bombs at pedestrians
i'll get dana prino to hand out jello
shots and jesse waters with a couple of
super soakers will fire tequila into the
faces of babies
pirates will be doing a dwarf toss which
will in fact be me
but don't worry about getting a traffic
ticket because i demand little
or no police presence see can just
anybody
plan public events and then tell the
cops to get lost
it's a weird time i have to say to ban
the police crime in
this city is exploding like pelosi's
head listening to a trump speech
a 36 percent increase in murder over
last year
shootings are up 77 percent and mayoral
stupidity is up a whopping 4 300 percent
look at this jackass look at him
i still can't get over this [ __ ] while
people are getting
stabbed on the subway lurch went on a
spending spree at the nba store
the guy is the charm of malaria every
day in new york
an elderly tourist or citizen is
attacked an 80 year old black veteran
just got
shot in the bronx yesterday the guy
fought in a war without getting wounded
but not the streets of this he couldn't
last the streets of new york
you're not supposed to be awarded a
purple heart because you were wounded in
action
in front of a tj max
and remember the people who show up
first to assist are the cops and the
first responders
but by all means reduce police presence
especially as hate crimes based on
sexual orientation
make up the second largest share of hate
crimes in 2019
trailing attacks on jews who have no
parade
something about it being too drafty
outside
[Laughter]
but you know who nabs the suspects not
the cast from queer eye
it's the cops so fewer cops means more
violence against the lgbt community
yet it's the cops that are the problem
that's like blaming fires on the fire
department
i mean they're often spotted near
burning buildings so there
has to be a connection
so again what we're seeing are people
cowering before overzealous activists
the gay officers action league sounds
like a marvel movie
calling it a shameful attempt to placate
some of the activists in our community
and they're right in the 1970s the early
days of pride gay police officers sued
the city of new york so they could
participate in the parade and they won
now they're being banned by calo
wokesters with no actual grip on
inclusion
and that's what this current moral panic
is all about it's about replacing actual
accomplishments with tantrums it
reflects a sad trend
the refusal to take a stand against a
handful of extremists
who act like a pack of hyenas spotting a
wounded lion
it's happening not just in parades but
in businesses and classrooms
i wonder what our angry white male has
to say
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how can you clap for that racist you
know i've never seen a parade for the
police
no wait i have they're called funerals
for their fallen comrades
who didn't freeze when duty called but
today when a large community encounters
the immovable extremists
they freeze they should fight back they
won't
they won't share the risk that's not a
parade it's a retreat
and it's not one to be proud of either
[Applause]
she's the first lawyer i'd call when i'm
facing murder charges
again outnumbered co-host emily compagno
if he were any more of a hero he'd come
covered with lettuce and mayo
that's my dream retired u.s marine corps
bomb technician and bus news contributor
joey jones
put on some bug repellent she's about to
drain the swamp
american conservative union foundation
senior fellow and former white house
director of strategic communications
mercedes
[Applause]
and she laughed at the end of titanic
fox's contributor
emily it's well known that you hate the
police but love a parade
so this is right up your alley you sick
person
you know your intro reminded me that
glitter bomb one of the best revenge
stories i heard
was from my girlfriend who got cheated
on snuck into her ex's
house and dumped glitter everywhere yes
it's like dating a stripper
exactly you can't it's all over your
clothes
not that i know better to sew fish on
the bottom of the curtains
i froze a fish duct tape duct taped it
under the seat of the driver's seat of a
car
so days later when it defrosted that's
when it would stink
even better so as you pointed out knypd
officers had to sue
to be allowed to march in the parade in
uniform and i just can't imagine what it
feels like
to be excluded from an entire community
that not only you've sworn to protect
but also that you thought was your home
and i feel like we're seeing that all
across the country right with
with defunding happening and calls to
get out of the community you're not
welcome here but they
are a part of the community that's the
point that police are part of the
community
and i think it interestingly the
backdrop the parade's mission
is in part to celebrate the unique
attributes that make up every single
each person
what are they doing right now they're
they're excluding
and being so divisive um
it just you know i think it's one more
example of the vocal minority
that that says that they speak for the
majority but most often they're dead
wrong
and i just wonder how many new new york
um
lgbtq members think this ban is as
shameful as we do well the the
parade started because of you know the
riot that was violent at the stone well
the only excuse me the police raid that
was violent at stonewall
a lot of people know that what a lot of
people don't know is one of the main
organizers of the parade
then went on to become a gay cop and he
because he wanted to help kind of change
things right from the inside and
uh he reached the rank of lieutenant so
i feel as though if you're
you know your parade you the person who
started it wouldn't be welcome at it you
probably kind of lost sight of what it
was supposed to be about and also i am
failing to understand i guess what
they're saying they're concerned about
you know they will get in trouble for
something and have a confrontation with
the police officer
that will go badly but as someone who's
been to the new york pride parade a few
times
what do you think you would get in
trouble for that's true
like it seems like pretty much anything
is allowed
yeah that is a fair point fair point and
you were i mean you managed to embarrass
embarrass yourself it's hard to do but i
am a champion
yes that's true mercedes the problem i
have here
is like we are now entering a phase
where sympathizing with the police or
defending the police is now seen as
racist it's like somehow an example of
white supremacy
so it actually scares people from coming
out and saying nice things about the
police
right and i think you're seeing so many
of these police officers
many who are minority we have obviously
those from the lgbtq community
also who are heroes and what's so sad is
when i've met with several of these
police officers
you know they almost break down in tears
because they they're like we're being
demonized my kids don't want to go into
law enforcement
and they're there doing their job i got
to tell you i think that they should
show up like
just in like suit and tie nobody knows
undercover
and that could be a way to do it but let
me tell you these progress that will not
look good in a parade
i don't know they can get away with it
they will stand out or
dress up like firefighters i don't know
like put on a different there's already
guys dressed up like firefighters
you can get away with maybe a tie and
that's it
it's going to be a chippendale's time a
sparkly time that's what we've got to do
but you know the progressives are all
about inclusion
yeah that they are the most the the
group that excludes people the most they
are the most intolerant
people and the mere fact is is that we
have to keep defending the cops
and keep pushing for uh making sure that
americans realize that they are our
heroes that they're there to keep our
community safe
including the lgbtq community yeah you
know
joey this this feels in a way like like
high school
like you're not you're not included in
our games
right doesn't it feel that way kind of
you know it's it's all
right i mean
i'm not gay okay but i was in the marine
corps
yes okay and let me tell you
i don't know the sexual orientation of
most of the straight men i served with
just based on their actions alone
right we had a great time and uh this is
what i'll tell you
your sexual orientation doesn't make you
honorable
and it doesn't give you an identity it
doesn't give you anything it's just who
you
are right right and so if you're my
point here
is if you want to have a gay pride
parade bring in the people within your
community
that are honorable and serve your
community and in our
ambassadors for i guess what what the
pride parade is about
but you know really what confuses me
about this is go back to where all this
began you know
back when i don't know we were rioting
and people were burning down buildings
the cities that stopped that from
starting were the ones where
the black cop went out and spoke to
people the ones where the march
that what could have been a riot became
a protest because the police department
was with him
right and held the megaphone and
listened to him and took the insults and
then made friends out of it
and we've gone from there to you can't
even be here in uniform because we hate
you
because we ain't you and you know like
where are we with this
yeah and it's because there's no
principle behind it there's no value
behind it
there's no truth behind it it's us
against them it's team politics
and it's the worst of who we can be and
it sure as hell isn't the place i fought
for
very good point you know i think your
arms could get its own float
pride parade you know you were so
complimentary of them last time i
thought i'd bring them back yeah
i want a short person parade
why can't i have a short person parade i
could be the grand marshal
brag you can do whatever you want no you
know what i when you can't go
i can't go to other parades because i
can't see over the backs of people
so i want a parade where i can actually
see what's going on i was wondering why
greg gutfeld day is only ten to three
and why do you sell yourself so short on
it it's a 24-hour day
man that's the busiest thing all right
joey
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else